this week on world stories fighting over
water in Kenya a home for prisoners
children in china but first to France
where the presidential election campaign
is entering the home stretch polls
suggest the independent a money where
Macomb is a strong contender against
former CEO nas Marvin repent attention
French Obama coming through that's what
it feels like when a man red McCall
enters the exhibition hall in Marseilles
ascend Bank a moose is one of his
biggest fans he never used to be
involved in politics but when McCraw
left the Socialists and founded his own
movement ormoc ascend became a
passionate supporter hey you but I'm
speechless that's how happy I am just
overwhelmed many people in France
obviously feel the same way the
self-styled centrist is leading in the
polls but this French campaign cycle is
turbulent voter intentions are changing
quickly and shooting star macro is young
and relatively inexperienced a sin
thinks that's the candidate strong point
he's on the streets non-stop to keep the
buzz surrounding mccall going at a
market in downtown Marseille he
campaigns for his candidate this
neighborhood has a strong migratory
background and people like what he's
saying but even my call comes with
political baggage these taxi drivers
haven't forgotten that as minister of
economy in the socialist government
Maccon sided with the transportation
service uber ascend tries hard to win
over the drivers but they haven't
forgiven my call for helping the
American competition
at the campaign event Michael's
supporters associate completely
different values with their candidate
when you let him know renewal plug Matty
Smith pragmatism that seek me fees do he
stands for Europe a minor Ian McCall has
become a screen onto which french voters
are projecting their dreams perhaps
because he talks little about concrete
proposals but he tries to reach out to
everyone I don't know eat that I use
your phone I sell you wherever I go and
must say I see Moroccans Tunisians
listen is young people from Mali chef
wanted men young but what do I really
see what well I see people living in
Marseille what else do i see i see
French citizens and it's looking likely
that he will also become Francis next
president if he does he'll have to try
not to crush all those hopes and
expectations they're huge just as they
were with Obama
dropped in northern Kenya has caused
much suffering for the people there the
situation has been made even more
complex by an influx of refugees from
neighboring countries
[Music]
hunger has already ravaged his tiny body
Abdul Rahim is fighting for his life in
the Kakuma refugee camp in northern
Kenya the Somalian seven months old and
suffering from pneumonia and diarrhea so
far this year this hospital has treated
more than 200 children with acute
menorah Schmidt and the numbers are
growing but for some help arrives too
late right now because of the lack of
food we are getting a lot of cases of
marasmus children are not getting enough
food so you find that they come in very
wasted the Kakuma General Hospital is
providing medical care to 180,000
refugees most are from South Sudan
fleeing conflict and drought in the home
country at the Kakuma came they can
escape the fighting but not the severe
shortages of food and water members of
Kenya's Turkana ethnic minority live
right next to the cam the semi nomadic
pastoralists have been hit hard by the
drought why the international community
provides 8 for the refugees the Kenyan
government is responsible for its own
people like Gallagher II we should get
the same as the refugees they come to
our land and use our resources we have
the same right to receive a llegar como
ganado modem louie not a runway in a new
settlement away from the overcrowded
camp the United Nations is trying to
help refugees and local peoples together
it's an attempt to promote integration
and trade but the local head of un
operations admits the project is
struggling it lacks adequate funding and
there is not enough supplies to go
around what we observe is the host
community blocking in unison vehicle
going to the settlement not eager to
request the back to the settlement
and do whenever we ask them visit they
need water the Kakuma hospital is also
offering care to locals and new arrivals
abdur-rahim is now getting life-saving
oxygen and fluids and for his mother
there's good news doctors have told her
that her son will survive US President
Donald Trump has long promised to
renegotiate the free trade agreement
nafta mexican imports he says hurt us
jobs but cities on both sides of the
border could lose out if restrictions
are imposed
every day as many as 2,000 trucks
crossed the veterans bridge connecting
Brownsville with Matamoros materials
components and finished products making
their way from one side of the border to
the other NAFTA's boosted Brownsville's
economy says Jason hilts the city's head
of economic development he thinks it's
wrong to denounce the agreement it
should be revisited it should be looked
at it should be strengthened for all
players see what what no provisions
aren't working what provisions need to
be at it because it's a new economy
should it be thrown away no Brownsville
has done well out of the tax free trade
with Mexico and the cross-border tourism
but business is no longer booming here
the week peso is to blame a result of
President Donald Trump's threats to
Mexico some here call it the Trump
effect less people from Mexico coming
over as it used to be before we had a
lot of sales but i want to say the sales
have dropped dramatically this year yeah
this year and actually part of last year
too as well matomoto City on the other
side of the border is one of Mexico's
fastest-growing municipalities tens of
thousands of people work here in the 120
manufacturing operations or maquiladoras
that produce electronics and car parts
for the United States the maquiladoras
association's local president Rolando
Gonzalez Peron says while he's not
worried others seem to be the only
impact that we seen as a lot of
companies that are waiting the decision
to came and invest in Mexico because
they want to see was going to be the end
result of the negotiation of NAFTA and
we are not seeing companies they used to
be coming more often we don't see this
right now back in Texan Brownsville
Jason hilts also has investors on his
mind he believes in his city's potential
and knows how strongly connected it is
to its Mexican twin
if we didn't have those manufacturing
plants and Matsumoto's you know half of
our investment in Brown's in terms of
warehousing space industrial buildings
and some of our companies would not
exist business people here hope it'll
only be a matter of time before Trump
and his administration understand how
truly interdependent the two sides of
the border are
our last report takes us to China the
children of parents who end up in prison
are often left to fend for themselves we
visited a village not far from Beijing
where people are trying to change that
[Music]
it's pure luck that jolly that's not her
real name isn't sleeping in the streets
she'd been living in a small remote
village with her father a convict who'd
fled jail then came the day four years
ago when everything changed I didn't
know what was going on with my father
but suddenly police turned up in our
village and arrested him then they put
me in a car and drove away well you're
gonna die for a truck dulla a policeman
had heard about sun village a community
for children of prisoners the state-run
orphanages refused to take them in so if
it weren't for this place the kids would
be on their own they're uncomfortable
discussing their parents but once a year
these to visit their fathers often I
don't understand what my dad is saying
to me I've already forgotten our dialect
jungkook in a former journalist founded
this children's village 20 years ago
after meeting inmates when she worked
for the prison authorities newspaper how
media no were you home did they would
often ask me to find out what had become
of their children they'd lost contact
with them and there was no one to take
care of them sundays are busy at sun
village visitors from Beijing arriving
tourist buses to donate clothing or to
help out while others come out of sheer
curiosity to see how children of
prisoners are faring I wanted to show my
daughter what it's like here so she can
see how these children live and learn
how she wants to take part in society
when we come back you'll work hard at
school right compared to these poor kids
you're doing really well aren't you
visitors to sun village are also treated
to some entertainment
grandma Jang as the children call the
village director has no qualms about
showing visitors around their dance
performances and contact with visitors
the children learn how to deal with
their situation and be open about it our
butcher long may be one of the visitors
turned out to be an old acquaintance of
jellies they're so sweet I love them one
student comes regularly to play music
with the children music also helps jaldi
gain self-confidence that's something
she'll need as an adult when she's
likely to face unsettling questions
about her family background
[Music]
you